Perfekt. Ja, dann willkommen zum Python Crash Course E, diesmal über Data Science und Bandas.
Bevor wir beginnen, habe ich euch Feedback angelegt. Da könnt ihr diesmal fragen,
falls ihr noch Fragen habt, ob sie live vorprogrammieren oder zum generell programmieren selbst
oder andere Fragen. Also, die Ergebnisse werden ein bisschen länger dauern, weil wir alle
manuell durchkorrigieren müssen. Das sind ca. 100 Abgaben, wahrscheinlich bei die 1, 2 Wochen.
Die Ergebnisse werden ihr wahrscheinlich im Deed-Center auffinden und ich weiß ja,
ob wir noch eine Mail, eine Info-Mail ausschicken werden.
Das Samen 2 werde ich heute bis die Vorstellung am Ende der Vorlesung. Ihr werdet dafür eben auch
das heutige Thema wissen müssen und auch das von der nächsten Vorlesung, das der Helmut dann noch
präsentieren wird. Das ist über Sympai. Sympai wurde von den letzten Studenten also gefragt,
weil das später noch mal in eurem Studium vorkommt und da haben viele gefragt, ob wir da nicht
ein kleines fundamentales Tutorial drüber machen können, damit ihr da nicht als Experten schon
einsteigen müsst in die spätere Vorlesung.
Ich sehe, es gibt keine Fragen zum Programmieren. Das heißt, ich habe da wahrscheinlich die einzigen
Guten hier im Raum. Falls ihr nach Fragen aufkommen, weil ihr euch gestern beim Vorprogrammieren
richtig geärgert habt, dass es nicht funktioniert hat, könnt ihr das natürlich auch fragen.
Also, können wir auf jeden Fall was machen und sonst steige ich direkt ins Data Science-Deme ein.
Die Punktaufteilung vom Vorprogrammieren weiß ich jetzt leider auch nicht ganz genau, aber wir haben
da eigentlich eine spezifische Punktetabelle, nachdem wir vorgehen. Es ist ja so, dass beim
Vorprogrammieren habt ihr erstens wenig Zeit, zweitens seid ihr unter sehr hohen Druck und
da könntest du mal einige Fehler passieren. Und manche Fehler wie zum Beispiel, wenn man
jetzt ein String falsch hat, sind jetzt nicht so problematisch wie wenn man jetzt nicht verstanden
hat, wie man ein Dictionary bedient. Das heißt praktisch, ihr könnt euch darunter so was vorstellen,
wie schwerer der Code zu programmieren war, desto mehr Punkte hat. Aber wir werden so versuchen,
so groß wie möglich zu sein. Und falls es dann immer noch nicht passt, das sagt okay,
da hätte ich mehr verdient, dann könnt ihr immer noch zum Tutorial kommen und dann noch mal nach
Auskunft fragen und diskutieren. Passt, dann werde ich da stoppen. Perfekt. Ja, dann
kurz Southland heute. Also wir werden heute ein Introduction zu Data Science machen.
Das beinhaltet, wie man CSV-Files oder CSV-Dateien einliest und was überhaupt CSV-Dateien sind.
Wir gehen auch nochmal genau auf dieses Import-Modul ein oder was es da auf sie hat.
Dann, der Großteil der Vorlesung wird ein Bandage Tutorial sein. Also da gehen wir ganz genau
ein, was Bandage ist und was man damit anfangen kann, weil ihr Bandage dann auch für das Assignment
2 brauchen wird. Und dann noch kurz ein organisatorisches und kurz das Assignment 2. So, was ist Data Science?
Ja, also Data Science meistens eigentlich ein unnötiges Passwort. Warum? Ja, weil, wie macht man
Wissenschaft ohne Daten? Science Englisch für Wissenschaft, weil das jemand nicht weiß.
Und in Wirklichkeit ist das kein eigenes Forschungsgebiet, sondern besteht aus mehreren
Fachübergreifenden Fähigkeiten. Die könnt ihr da sehen. Und die haben Anwendungen in
industriellen und akademischen Bereichen und wird immer, immer wichtiger heutzutage. Ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr das schon mal gehört habt. Zum Beispiel, so ein Passwort ist Building Information Modeling,
zum Beispiel. Da baut man mit der Software eigentlich ein ganzes Gebäude nach und simuliert
das Gebäude. Das heißt, man kann auch da zum Beispiel herausfinden, wie viel mir die Wartungskosten in
den nächsten 20 Jahren kosten wird. Und das ist ja praktisch. Und dafür braucht man natürlich
sehr viele Daten. Das heißt, wir haben da vereint drei verschiedene Bereiche. Unser Bereich wird
jetzt vor allem hier sein mit Pfeifen und Bandas und Nampaioch. Sind wir dann Hacking Skills oder
eigentlich ist einfach nur der informatische Teil davon. Und Data Science vereint praktisch Skills
von den Statistikern. Das ist hier in der Mathe Bereich, welche Datenmengen modellieren und
zusammenfassen können. Dann haben wir die Arbeiterinformatiker, die eben durch Algorithmen
das Ganze sehr effizient verarbeiten können und visualisieren können, weil wir reden hier nicht
nur von ein paar Hundertzeilen Daten, sondern manchmal sind das aber also Milliarden oder sogar
noch mehr. Also da reden wir von Gigabyte oder Terabyte an Daten. Und dann brauchen wir natürlich
aber auch die Expertise von den Fachexperten. Also die sind natürlich auch notwendig, weil
ich kann schon Daten von einem Haus sammeln, aber wenn ich da nur, keine Ahnung, schaubt, das Licht ein
und aus geht, jeden Tag, das wird wahrscheinlich für einen Bauingenieur nicht sehr hilfreich sein. Der
wird wahrscheinlich andere Daten viel wichtiger finden und deshalb kommt der Bauingenieur zu den
Informatikern oder Statistikern und sagt, ja diese Daten brauche ich, damit ich was anfangen kann.
Ja und das Ganze ist sehr interdisziplinär, also das ist natürlich nicht nur im Bauingenieurswesen,
sondern auch in allen möglichen, also das Recht von Psychologie zu Soziologie, zu
Mathematik, alles Mögliche eigentlich, Elektrotechnik, Maschinenbau
und ja vielleicht noch kurz zu den einzelnen Bubbles, die wir hier sehen. Wir haben hier noch
zum Beispiel dieses Traditional Research. Traditional Research könnt ihr so vorstellen,
das ist jetzt ohne Informatik, das heißt der Experte braucht eine Formel oder irgendeine
statistische Analyse, weil er schon Daten hat und dann gibt hier einfach der Mathematiker
einen Statistiker her und sagt, ja okay, diese Formeln müssen wir anwenden und das hat eigentlich
nichts mit den Informatik zu tun, vielleicht ein bisschen was mit Axel, aber relativ klein.
Dann haben wir auch das Machine Learning Teil hier, das ist eigentlich
Überlappung zwischen den Informatikern und Mathematikern, hier versuchen wir so Regressionen
zu machen oder ja einfach auch wieder praktisch mathematische Modelle aufzustellen,
die wir dann in der Informatik anwenden können. Und dann gibt es eigentlich noch diese Danger Zone
hier und die ist eigentlich, kann man fast sagen gefährliches Halbwissen, das heißt
wir, der Experte zum Beispiel kommt zu uns, zu den Informatikern und sagt, ja er braucht
den Algorithmus und bitte mach mir was, aber eine Informatik kann ich sagen,
nicht unbedingt der beste Mathematiker, das heißt es kann sein, dass er dann zum Beispiel
eine falsche Statistik verwendet oder falsche mathematische Formel anwendet und dann kommen
wir zu sehr plausiblen Ergebnissen, die beim Wirklichkeit nicht stimmen. Ja, das ist ungefähr
der Data Science zusammengefasst, also hier nochmal Expertenwissen. Genau, dann kurz zum Inboard.
Ihr habt es wahrscheinlich eh schon mal gesehen, jetzt sehen wir es mal mit einem zum Beispiel,
da importieren wir die Math Library und das Inboard-Keywort, mit dem können wir praktisch
Funktionalität von anderen Python-Files oder Scripts oder Modulen praktisch importieren.
Zum Beispiel, ich habe jetzt zwei Daten, zwei Python-Dateien und in der einen habe
ich eine tolle Funktion geschrieben und die möchte ich jetzt in der anderen Datei verwenden,
dann kann ich die einfach praktisch mit diesem Inboard-Statement importieren. Das heißt,
ich kann der Code Bausteine von anderen Bibotheken oder einfach Python-Files hernehmen
und in meinem Python-File verwenden. Und da habe ich das eh schon gesagt, Bibotheken,
da sind praktisch diese Libraries und das sind meistens externe Code Bibotheken
und die kann man eben mit diesem Python, mit diesem PIP installieren. PIP steht für PIP installs
Packages. Cool, cooles Akronym. Und einerseits haben wir eben dieses PIP und einerseits haben wir
diese Python Standard Library. Zum Beispiel, dieses Math, diese Math Library, die wir importiert haben
in der Cymint1, das ist eine Standard Library. Ich kann das kurz zeigen, wenn wir da draufklicken.
Das sehen wir praktisch eigentlich alles, was Python so an sich hat.
Und hier fangen wir praktisch eigentlich so, also diese, man sieht hier die Schriftart,
ist ein bisschen anders. Das sind praktisch alles Standard Libraries und da gibt es sehr, sehr,
sehr viele. Und zum Beispiel dieses Math habt ihr schon kennengelernt, aber da gibt es eben auch so,
weil ich, also die haben dann größere Überschriften, zum Beispiel hier, die haben alles mit Files zu tun,
File Format, dann hier zum Beispiel kryptografische Services,
die sind generische Betriebsoperationssystems, Services.
Ja, könnt euch ruhig mal durchschauen. Es ist auf jeden Fall interessant, weil wahrscheinlich,
falls ihr was praktisch programmieren wollt, gibt es wahrscheinlich schon.
Und das andere wäre praktisch eigentlich PIP. Da kann ich das auch kurz zum Beispiel zeigen,
das wäre hier PIP, zum Beispiel Pandas.
Da sieht man zum Beispiel immer, wie man so ein Paket installieren kann, also es ist dann einfach
PIP Install Pandas, in diesem Fall. Und Pandas hier zum Beispiel, hier sieht man die ganzen Informationen
zu diesem, zu diesem, dieser Pivotek. Und da gibt es natürlich unmenschlich viele,
also da kann man dann oben hier suchen. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt Karnung
möchte, was suchen, zum Beispiel irgendwas über Machine Learning, da kann ich zum Beispiel schauen.
Ein ganz bekanntes ist zum Beispiel By-Touch.
Also, das heißt By-Touch.
Und da zum Beispiel hat man dann eine ganze Pivotek, mit dem man praktisch Machine Learning
betreiben kann. Und die können natürlich sehr, sehr, sehr stark sein, also da kann Funktionalität
drin sein, wo man selber wahrscheinlich Jahre bräuchte, um das zu programmieren.
Meistens diese Pakete werden auch von Hunderten von Leuten gleichzeitig also programmiert, also
da wird dann aufgeteilt, wer was macht. Und deshalb geht das dann auch so flott.
Aber ja auch By-Touch ist jetzt, glaube ich, seit über zehn Jahren in Entwicklung. Also,
so was würde man nie selber eigentlich programmieren. Auch zum Beispiel kryptografische
Pivotek, die sind immer besser, wenn man sie runterlässt, statt sich selber zu programmieren,
weil man kann sich vorstellen, ein Back-Und schon ist ein ganzes kryptografisches Verfahren kaputt.
Aber ja, das ist für euch hier nicht so richtig.
Genau. Genau, das heißt praktisch, wir importieren hier Module und das sind dann unsere Werkzeuge,
die wir aus der Werkzeugkiste nehmen und die können wir dann verwenden.
Zum Sintax vielleicht kurz noch, wir können einfach Import und dann den Modulnamen schreiben.
Das wird uns eine Fehler werfen, falls der Modulnamen nicht existiert oder wir den noch nicht
installiert haben mit pip install. Also, falls ihr da eine Fehlermellung kriegt,
dann vielleicht schaut ihr, ob der dann nochmal mit pip install das installiert.
Ihr könnt dann auch noch hier mit ass ein Kürzel definieren. Hier zum Beispiel sieht man das
gut, pandasas.pd. Und dann kann man da statt den ganzen Modulnamen, der vielleicht auch sehr
lang sein kann, einfach dieses Kürzel verwenden. Und dann kann man da Kürzelpunkt und dann Funktionsnamen
zum Beispiel, wenn man da Funktionen von dieser Bibothek verwenden will. Das schaut zum Beispiel
so aus. Ich kann hier zum Beispiel random als rd importieren und dann hat dieses Random-Bibothek
zum Beispiel diese rd int Funktion, die praktisch unsere Randomzahl zwischen 1 und 13 einfach wählt
und die wir dann hier in diese variabel speichern können. Also, ich kann das auch kurz zeigen.
Zum Beispiel random, ganz wichtig ist auch eine der Standard-Bibotheken. Schau mal.
Ich kann da praktisch ganz oben hier, schauen, ob ich das größer machen kann.
Dann kann ich eben, also wenn ich hier zum Beispiel ein Wischlerstudekord bin,
dann sehe ich auch automatisch, welche Funktionen ich zur Verfügung habe. Und die fangen dann
hier alle an. Und wie ihr seht, da gibt es dann sehr, sehr viele. Wir wollen hier zum Beispiel
diese rd int. Und da seht ihr auch auf der Seite hier zum Beispiel eine kurze Beschreibung,
was die macht. Return random integer in range ab, including both endpoints. Das heißt praktisch
sowohl a als b kann auch noch gezogen werden. Das heißt, wenn ich hier 1 und 5 mache und das ausführe,
da bekomme ich diesmal 4. Wenn ich das nochmal ausführe, dann bekomme ich eine andere Zahl.
Also wie ihr seht, kann dem anders sein. Jetzt zum Beispiel was die selbe.
Genau, ja. Ich hab's ja zur Frage. Also das Kürzel hier ist nicht unbedingt notwendig.
Dann müsst ihr aber hier dann random schreiben.
Und wenn ihr das import vergisst, dann sagt es hier auch schon gleich random is not defined.
Random existiert praktisch nicht. Ist nicht definiert.
Diesmal geht's. Warum? Weil ich
wenn ich jupiter in jupiter arbeite und das einmal ausgeführt hab,
dann merkt sich das jupiter und man muss es nicht zweimal oder dreimal importieren.
Zum Beispiel wenn ich es jetzt ausführe, wo praktisch alles gelöscht wurde,
dann bekomme ich diesen name error.
So, was machen wir so?
Genau, dann kommen wir zu den csv Dateien. csv Dateien, hier ein tolles Beispiel.
Das heißt einfach comma separated values. Praktisch comma separiert. Wir haben hier
praktisch irgendwelche Werte drin stehen. Komma, dann der nächsten Wert. Komma und so weiter.
Und sofort. Das Wichtige dabei ist, dass hier, wenn wir hier vier Spalten definieren am Anfang,
hier mal Trikelnummer vorne, dann mal nachher mit Punkte,
da müssen die darauf folgenden auch immer vier sein.
Und das schaut dann in Excel zum Beispiel so aus, das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich eh alle.
Und genau, das ist einfach der Werte in einem Tabellenformat.
Und ganz wichtig, das muss nicht nur nimmer ein Comma sein, das kann auch andere Werte sein,
zum Beispiel, wie interessant es sind, dieses Semikolon, also Strichpunkt oder zum Beispiel auch Tabulator.
Genau, und wie kann man mit denen in Beifen arbeiten? Da gibt es mehrere Varianten.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel dieses csv Package, das ist auch wieder eine Standard Library
oder eben mit Banders, das werden wir jetzt dann machen.
Genau, zur Banders. Also wie ihr seht, Banders ist eigentlich ziemlich ähnlich wie Excel,
also ihr könnt euch das so vorstellen, dass ihr da auch wieder so Tabellen habt.
Aber das coole ist, dass ihr da nicht nur, keine Ahnung, 100 Zeilen,
oder wenn man mit Excel mit 100.000 Zeilen arbeitet, ist das schon sehr unübersichtlich.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wenn man das ganze visuell machen muss, zum Beispiel da
eine Formel herunterziehen muss in einer Spalte, dann kann das sehr viel Zeit beanspruchen.
Banders, da können wir dann Beifencode verwenden und dann geht das sehr schnell,
da kann man in einer Zeile auf eine Milliarde Zeilen zugreifen.
Und das geht alles auf dem Laptop, also das ist kein Problem.
Und da kann man eben Excel-Dateien oder eben csv Tabellen einlesen.
Und das Wichtigste eigentlich für euch zu wissen ist, also so was nennt man ein Data Frame,
das ist praktisch
Netabelle, die besteht eigentlich aus mehreren Listen, also die Spalten hier sind einfach Listen.
Und man kann dann eigentlich sehr ziemlich ähnlich zugreifen wie Dictionaries,
nur sind diese Banders Data Frames noch viel stärker als eben Dictionaries.
Da gehen wir dann eh gleich drauf ein und generell einfach Banders verwenden wir
für praktisch eine effiziente Datenverwaltung, das heißt wir können da wie gesagt auf Milliarden
von Daten gleichzeitig zugreifen und die verändern. Und ja, da hat eben verschiedene
Funktionalitäten, Ladenspeichern, Zugriff, Filtern von Daten. Wir können fehlende oder
fehlerhafte Daten ausbessern. Wir können Ergebnisse berechnen, zum Beispiel wollen
wir den Mittelwert berechnen, dann ist das ganz einfach möglich. Wir können die Tabelle
erweitern, wenn wir möchten. Und auch ganz cool ist, wir können auch blotten, das heißt wir können
grafen erstellen und ja, da möchte ich euch da ein bisschen was zeigen heute.
Zuerst mal, wie kann man so ein Data Frame überhaupt anlegen? Und da gibt es mehrere
Möglichkeiten, da kann man zum Beispiel das Ganze mit einem Dictionary machen.
Hier seht ihr zum Beispiel haben wir Population Area hier als Spalten.
Das heißt wir haben hier Population und Area und dann haben wir hier für die einzelnen
Zeilen nochmal ein Dictionary. Und da gehen wir dann einfach her, okay für Population, also für
Population für diesen Bereich hier, möchten wir für Kalifornia den Wert drin stehen haben,
für New York den Wert stehen haben und für Florida den Wert stehen haben. Und für Area,
also für diese Spalter hier wollen wir diese Werte drin haben. Und dann kann man das ganze
Dictionary einfach in so ein Data Frame konvertieren, wenn wir einfach bd, also pandas,
Punkt Data Frame aufrufen und dann in den Klammern drin das Dictionary. Die andere Möglichkeit,
was wir machen können, ist das Ganze mit Listen machen. Und das ist einfach eine
zweidimensional Liste, praktisch eine Liste in Listen. Und da definieren wir einfach immer eine
ganze Zeile, also Kalifornia den Wert den Wert, also den Wert den Wert, New York den Wert den Wert,
New York den Wert den Wert und so weiter und so fort. Das ist natürlich sehr umständlich und
meistens wird es sehr schnell unübersichtlich und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wenn ich davor
von Milliarden von Daten geredet habe, dann werde ich das Ganze hier nicht so machen.
In der Praxis laden wir eher Daten von CSV, CSV Tabellen oder von anderen Data ein. Da gibt es
natürlich auch noch viel effizientere Formate als CSV, aber die müsst ihr eigentlich für diese
Vorlesung nicht wissen. Die können aber daneben Binary gespeichert werden und sind dann viel
effizienter. Genau, wie lesen wir so eine CSV-Datei ein? Ja, das machen wir einfach mit Read CSV.
Das heißt, wir haben hier zum Beispiel eine CSV-Datei, also wenn wir die in Excel aufmachen,
dann schaut das so aus und im Bandage können wir dann einfach hier Bandage importieren und dann
read CSV, eben eine CSV-Datei einlesen und dann BAM, haben wir hier die Tabelle, ich kann das auch
kurz vorzeigen. Okay, also noch mal kurz zur Aufrichtung hier zum Beispiel, das funktioniert
nicht, dann können wir hier mit PIP install Bandage. Ihr seht, habe ich hier einfach ein Rufzeichen
davor gemacht, dann kann ich eben so Kommands einfügen, die ich normalerweise im Terminal aufrufe.
Jetzt hat es mir hier Bandage installiert. Jetzt, wenn ich das nochmal ausführe, funktioniert,
also das haben wir gerade durchgemacht und hier zum Beispiel habe ich eine CSV-Datei, die schaut so
aus und dann kann ich die einfach einlesen. Und da hat man auch irgendwie für das Studio Code
eigentlich eine tolle Übersicht, also da kann man zum Beispiel hier auch so filtern direkt schon,
also zum Beispiel, wenn wir die aufsteigend haben, dann kann ich die Wert aufsteigend anzeigen und wenn
ich da natürlich Dausende von Zeilen habe, dann kann ich die alle anschauen. Genau. Dann kommen wir
zum nächsten, also wie greif ich da zum Beispiel auf einzelne Spalten zu? Da gibt es mehrere Varianten,
da gibt es zum Beispiel, dass ich das so mache wie ein Dictionary zum Beispiel, also ich habe hier
diese spalte Area und dann kann ich da entweder so zugreifen mit einem Stringkey, praktisch einfach
schreibe ich da einfach Area rein oder ich kann auch Bandage mit dem Hintergrund direkt eine lokale
Variable, das heißt ich kann dann auch hier einfach Punkt Area so hinschreiben oder zum Beispiel auch
mit diesem Punkt Lock, das ist das Location, die Location Methode, da kann ich auch zum
Beispiel zugreifen. Genau und wenn ich Lock ist eigentlich ein sehr starkes Tool, dann kann ich zum
Beispiel einfach auch mit Index zugreifen, den Indexidema hier oder ihr könnt auch zum Beispiel
auf eine gewisse Range zugreifen, zum Beispiel ich möchte hier von 2 bis 4 zugreifen in Area,
dann ist das komplett möglich, also kann ich das kurz zeigen. Also hier haben wir noch mal mit Index,
aber wir können natürlich auch zum Beispiel 2 bis 5 machen und dann Area und dann seht der bekam
wir hier 2 bis 5 die Area Werte. Genau. Genau. Der Unterschied ist eben hier sind Spalten,
und hier machen wir Zeilen. Genau. Was auch cool ist mit Bandages, manchmal will man nicht alle
Daten haben, sondern will nur spezifisch welche haben und dann können wir das DataFrame filtern
und da gibt es verschiedene Filteroperationen und zum Beispiel die Vergleichsoperatoren, die
kennt ihr wahrscheinlich eh schon, also die haben wir ja schon mal bei einem FLs durchgemacht, da
gibt es zum Beispiel größer, kleiner, größer gleich, kleiner gleich, ist gleich oder ist nicht
gleich. Es gibt auch die Logischenoperatoren, also die normalen Beifungen kennt man die ja mit
End oder Not, in Bandages kann man aber nur das Unzeichen, das Oderzeichen oder die Verneinung
mit der Tilde verwenden und da generiert man praktisch so eine Art Boolean-Maske, das heißt
praktisch, das werde ich gleich dann in der nächsten zeigen, macht man da gleich so, praktisch
wenn ich da zum Beispiel hier ein DataFrame habe und ich will nach Population filtern und zwar dass
ich will nur die Zeilen haben, die praktisch eine Population über 25 Millionen haben,
dann mache ich das einfach so, Df, ganz wichtig noch zu Df, also Df entspricht ja eigentlich
normalerweise nicht dem Coding-Standard, das hat sich so eingebürgert, dass Df kurz für DataFrame
steht und wenn ich mir richtig erinnere, könnt ihr Df auch dann in Assignment 2 so verwenden,
weil das ist einfach ein eingebürgertes Wort und wenn jemand Df in Code liest,
dann weiß eigentlich sofort jeder, okay, damit ist eigentlich ein DataFrame gemeint. Das kann
dann zum Beispiel auch Df Unterstrich States heißen, also wenn es falls ihr mehrere DataFrames
habt, genau und wenn wir jetzt da zum Beispiel nach Population filtern wollen, dann können wir da
eben Df, eckige Klammer aufmachen und dann haben wir da praktisch drin Df.population und dann hier
eben unseren Vergleichsoperator, also wenn man da kleiner haben will, dann macht man da kleiner,
wenn man gleich haben will, dann machen wir gleich und sonst eben größer und da gibt es auch wieder
verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie man da dieses Df.population drin machen kann. Da können wir zum
Beispiel das eben mit Df.population machen, wir können das aber auch wie im Dictionary machen,
also mit Anführungszeichen oder auch mit dem Location-Parameter oder halt Methode. Und was
passiert im Hintergrund? Im Hintergrund geht Bandas her und geht für jede Zeile her und sagt, okay,
ist dieser Wert größer als 25 Millionen? Ja, dann schreibt mir ein True da rein. Ist dieser Wert
größer als 25 Millionen? Ja, passt true. Falls, falls, falls, falls, also im Hintergrund macht
es uns dann so eine Liste, wo dann eben für jeden jede Zeile in der Spalte drin steht, ob die
Bedingungen war es oder nicht. Okay, dann zeige ich das kurz her. Also, genau so schaut das aus,
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel nur das Innere hier nehmen würde. Dann seht ihr, dass hier einfach True
oder false drin stehen wird. Gibt es da zu fragen? Okay, genau. Genau, und die kann man
eben kombinieren. Das macht man dann eben mit, mit diesem und oder oder Verneinung. Zum Beispiel hier
will ich abfragen, welche Zeilenbeinhalt starten mit weniger als 15 Millionen Einwohnern und weniger
als 200.000 Kilometer Fläche. Dann kann ich die einfach kombinieren. Dann sage ich, okay, der
Population soll kleiner sein. Und dann vergleiben wir noch die Area gleich da drin dazu und dann
können wir das kurz mal ausführen. Und dann sehen wir, okay, wir haben hier Hawaii, wo anscheinend
bei 0 sein soll und immer neu die 12 Millionen oder fast 13 Millionen Einwohner hat. Genau. Dann können wir zum
Beispiel auch die States rausfinden. Also hier davor hatten wir ja praktisch hier noch diese Zeile
State und wir haben dieses gefilterte Data Frame jetzt in einer neuen Data Frame abgespeichert und
dann können wir das neue Sachen abfragen, zum Beispiel eben hier die State Spalte.
Genau. Das schaut dann eben so aus zum Beispiel. Und das haben wir gerade durchgemacht. Genau. Was auch
ganz cool ist, wir können da zum Beispiel Stringen-Operationen durchführen. Zum Beispiel haben
wir hier unser Data Frame und da als Population und Area zum Beispiel, das sieht man sofort,
das sind Float Werte, weil die haben ja hier Punkt irgendwas stehen. Außer vielleicht der Wert hier,
in der einen da kommen wir dann später noch dazu, dass da praktisch fehlt ein Wert. Aber hier
diese Werte hier, das sind alle Strings. Und die können wir natürlich auch verändern. Da können
wir eben die normalen Stringen-Operationen ausführen, die ihr eh schon kennt, Punkt Lower, Punkt Upper,
Containen usw. und so fort. Und da kann ich zum Beispiel dann noch filtern. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich
jetzt alle Staaten haben will, die New drin haben in ihrem Namen, dann kann ich das so machen,
indem ich einfach sagt DF und dann schaue ich mir die States an, also diese Spalte hier und dann
kann ich Punkt STR machen. Praktisch dann weiß ich okay, ich will eine Stringer Funktion ausführen
und dann Punkt Contains und dann schaue ich einfach, ob dieses New Keyword drin vorhanden ist.
Also so, das kann ich auch kurz vorzeigen. Okay, schauen wir mal dann noch das originale DF.
Also das Wichtige ist eben, dass wir hier wieder diese Eckenklammern machen. DF, zum Beispiel State
kann man, dann wollen wir praktisch das ganze als String behandeln und dann können wir eben hier
zum Beispiel Contains machen und dann wollen wir herausfinden, zum Beispiel alle Staaten, die ein S
vorhanden haben. Das heißt hier DEXAS, New Jersey und Illinois haben praktisch ein S. Was kann ich da
noch machen? Ich kann zum Beispiel hergehen, also noch mal kurz Herzer zeigen, wenn ich die Eckenklammern
weglasse, dann kann man wieder nur dieses True-False. Aber was ganz cool ist, ist zum Beispiel, ich kann da nicht
nur Contains, also was zum Beispiel True oder False zurückgibt, ich kann da zum Beispiel eben auch
lower machen. Und dann verwandelt es mir praktisch alle Namen in Kleinbust haben. Oder Abba.
Gibt es da so Fragen? Okay. Genau, dann kann man eigentlich auch zu einem sehr starken Dual,
was dieses DataFrame eben auch bereitstellt und dass es eben diese Aggregierungsfunktionen
und da gibt es verschiedene, so gibt es zum Beispiel, man kann das ganze aufsummieren oder man kann den
höchsten Wert herausfinden, den kleinsten Wert herausfinden. Man kann natürlich auch herausfinden,
wie lang so ein DataFrame ist, also wie viele Zeilen ein DataFrame besitzt mit dem Length keyword. Das
ist praktisch sehr ähnlich zu dem von der Liste. Genau. Und was auch noch interessant ist, wir haben
da nicht nur was wir bei Listen haben, Sam, Max, Min, wir haben ja auch zum Beispiel, wir können
den Medien ausrechnen, den Mittelwert und zum Beispiel, wie oft ein Value vorhanden ist. Wie schaut
das aus, wenn ich das zum Beispiel mache? Sag mal, ich mache ein neues DataFrame.
Schauen wir mal, ob das geht.
Ich habe jetzt einfach mal ein DataFrame gestellt, dass praktisch diese Werte beinhalten. Wie ihr seht,
kann man da einfach auch eine einfache Liste übergeben und dann macht das einfach nur eine Spalte.
Und dann wollen wir da zum Beispiel herausfinden, was ist der kleinste Wert? Das anscheinend 1,
der größte Wert ist anscheinend 6. Dann können wir einen Min machen, dann kommen wir den Mittelwert
daraus und dann können wir zum Beispiel ValueCounts machen. Und das seht ihr, das ist jetzt bisschen blöd,
weil das in NumPy umgewandelt wird, aber schaut einfach diesen Wert in der Klammer an und dann seht
jetzt hier zum Beispiel, dass der Wert 2 anscheinend 2 mal vorkommt. Das heißt praktisch, wenn nicht zum
Beispiel im oberen DataFrame 2 mal Kalifornien drin haben würde, dann würde ValueCounts dann
Kalifornien hier stehen und hier 2. Damit kann sehr schnell praktisch Werte zählen. Das kann sehr praktisch sein.
Genau, was auch ganz interessant ist, ist, man kann eben auch so arithmetische Spaltenoperationen machen.
Was heißt das? Ich kann plus, minus, mal geteilt auf eine ganze Spalte anwenden.
Noch mal hier zum Beispiel. Also hier haben wir das. Und jetzt möchte ich aber das Ganze multiplizieren.
Dann kann ich das einfach machen. Null, warum steht hier Null drin? Weil unsere Spalte Null heißt.
Das heißt praktisch, wenn wir hier keine Spaltenamen angeben, dann tut uns Pan das einfach
irgendwelche Integer zuweisen. Ihr seht auch, das ist kein String. Also das ist wirklich ein Integer.
Also wenn ich das hier als Integer, als String schreiben würde, dann würde das nicht funktionieren.
Aber wenn eben zum Beispiel Area drin stehen würde, dann ist es automatisch ein String.
Genau, und da kann man ganz viel machen. Da kann man eben alle möglichen Operatoren anwenden.
So.
Im Hintergrund praktisch werden dann einfach, wird jedes Spalte als Serious-Objekt bearbeitet.
Das heißt praktisch, Serious könnt ihr euch vorstellen, ist einfach eine Pifenliste.
Bissich komplizierter, weil es effizient programmiert wird als eine Pifenliste.
Aber ihr könnt euch das wirklich so vorstellen, als wäre das einfach eine Pifenliste.
Und dieses Serious-Objekt eben besteht aus einem NumBuy Area, genau, und so weiter und so fort,
weil das Ganze ist dann nicht mehr beifenprogrammiert, sondern in C, weil das effizienter ist,
und dann im Hintergrund praktisch schneller arbeiten kann.
Ich kann hier zum Beispiel meine Area, die da vorhin squared miles war, in 1 km umrechnen,
wenn ich zum Beispiel den Faktor weiß, und kann das Ganze dann noch so aufsummieren,
dann weiß ich die Total Area, also eigentlich ein sehr starkes Tool.
Genau, also hier zum Beispiel,
natürlich wenn hier ein Nann drin steht, dann bleibt das Nann oder auch wenn das Null ist,
Null multipliziert mit irgendwas, ist wieder Null.
Und dann kommen wir auch zu diesem Nann, das sind praktisch fehlerhafte Daten,
das heißt praktisch die fehlen einfach in unser TSV Datei zum Beispiel,
und das ist eigentlich das Equivalent zu dem Nann, das wir hier schon gelernt haben.
Und wenn ich zum Beispiel keinen anderen drin stehen haben will, sondern zum Beispiel Null,
dann kann ich das mit diesem Fill Nah machen, also Fill NA,
und dann hier einfach einen Wert bereit geben, das heißt zum Beispiel,
wenn ich eben Null haben will, dann schreibe ich hier Null rein.
Jetzt können wir auch ausdessen,
gehen wir da zurück zu uns,
schauen wir mal.
Okay, dann müssen wir noch was hinzufügen.
Ich habe davor gesagt, dass TSV Dateien immer,
dann machen wir da einfach
die man dann nicht solle Idee für ein Start,
dann machen wir einfach, ah können, so,
da schreibe man Plation 1 rein, und hier fehlt dann ein Wert.
Bandas handelt das für uns, ohne Probleme.
Da steht hier einfach Missing Value drin, also Visual Studio Code zeigt es uns als
Missing Value an, im Hintergrund ist da dann einen anderen.
Kannst vergessen, dass wir das schon drin gehabt haben, bei den New Jersey,
das war schon tatsächlich, das fehlt hier auch.
Und dann können wir hergehen und sagen,
dann machen wir das ein bisschen kleiner hier,
Punktvillner,
da zum Beispiel minus 1.
Und dann haben wir hier statt Missing Value minus 1 drin.
Ja.
Dann muss das filtern,
da muss sagen, okay, ich
praktisch, sagen wir mal, du willst jetzt nur,
ich will jetzt nur von New Jersey den Wert, den Nahwert verändern,
da muss ich zuerst hergehen und mit df.loc,
dann zum Beispiel df.state ist gleich New Jersey machen,
jetzt bekommen wir New Jersey raus,
da geht man schon eher, also da braucht man dann nicht mal viel Nahverwenden,
da kann man dann einfach direkt zum Beispiel die Area verändern,
indem man einfach sagt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das so machen kann.
Ja.
Und dann kann ich eben so praktisch zum Beispiel den Nahwert verändern.
Also da, wenn du wirklich ganz spezifisch nur einen Wert verändern willst,
dann bist du einfach filtern und den Wert direkt auf was setzen.
Viel Nah ist eher so,
ich will jetzt einfach keine Missing Values drin haben,
weil ich, keine Ahnung, eine Funktion auf alle Spaltenwerte ausführen will
und die nicht miteinander arbeiten kann zum Beispiel.
Weil ich kann dann natürlich auch wirklich hergehen und sagen, okay,
ich habe hier mal ein Data Frame, ja,
und dann mache ich df., hol mir eine Spalte raus, zum Beispiel Area,
Punkt Ablei und da kann ich jetzt eine wirklich von mir definierte Funktion zum Beispiel ausführen,
also zum Beispiel Def,
Print Area, die bekommt dann den Wert natürlich, Area,
und dann,
machen wir so,
und dann gehe ich das nochmal zurück,
und jetzt hat es mir da einfach diese Funktion auf alle Spalten ausgeführt,
zum Beispiel mit diesem Ablei.
Was passiert, wenn ich hier kein Return Area mache,
dann geht bei FNaF unaus, dass du Return None machst,
das heißt, alle Area-Werte werden mit None überschrieben,
das heißt, jetzt hast du überall Missing Values drin stehen.
Aber cooler ist dann natürlich, wenn man da wirklich hergeht und okay,
was eine Berechnung machen will, zum Beispiel,
hoch 2, zum Beispiel,
da kann man natürlich sehr komplizierte Berechnungen auch machen.
Genau.
Man kann auf bestimmte Spalten hergehen,
man kann auf das gesamte DataFrame die Werte ändern,
also das würde ich nicht empfehlen,
weil, sagen wir zum Beispiel, man hat jetzt eine Spalte,
wo zum Beispiel die Namen der Staaten drin stehen hat,
und dann eine, wo die Area drin stehen hat,
und zusammen mit dem fehlt ein,
und zusammen mit dem fehlt ein Value bei den Staatennamen
und einer bei den Areas, und wir sagen einfach viel Namen mit minus 1,
dann haben wir jetzt auch bei den Staatennamen
an minus 1 drin stehen, und das ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt das,
was wir wollen.
Das Bessere, wir gehen wirklich nur her und machen für jede Spalte
einzelne was, und kann natürlich auch hierhergehen,
und für jede Spalte einen bestimmten Wert definieren,
also das geht auch.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, ja, wenn man mehrere Spalten gleichzeitig machen will.
Genau, damit ist ein bisschen was durchgemacht.
Ja, das heißt, ich kann hier einfach ein Missing Value
dann einfügen mit diesem Filter.
Ja, und wie gesagt, ich kann das Ganze dann eben auch mit diesem Filter machen,
und das, ja, wenn man ganz spezifisch was ändern will.
Nun kommen natürlich auch zu einem sehr anderen wichtigen Thema ist,
wie lege ich überhaupt Spalten an.
Und das geht eigentlich ganz easy.
Wenn ich eine Spalte machen will, dann mache ich einfach,
wie beim Liktion Arrow zum Beispiel, einfach einen neuen Wert für diese Spalte,
und dann einen Standard Wert.
Das kann ich so machen, das kann ich aber auch mit Location,
mit diesem Location Methode machen,
die ja ist sicherer, weil ich hier ganz spezifisch die Zeilen definieren kann.
Ich kann natürlich auch eine neue Spalte machen,
indem ich eine andere Spalte hernehme,
und da zum Beispiel sage, okay, ich möchte hier die Population in Millionen haben,
dann nehme ich einfach die normale Population,
spalte her und dividiere die durch eine Million.
Oder das Ganze geht natürlich auch mit mehr Spalten,
das heißt, ich kann hergehen und sage, okay, ich will die Density,
also die Bevölkerungstichte berechnen,
dass man mit Population als Bevölkerung durch die Fläche,
und dann wird praktisch wirklich für jede Zeile die Population,
der Population Wert hergenommen und der Area Wert hergenommen,
und die zwei werden dann kombiniert,
um dann einen neuen Wert in dieser Zeile in der neuen Spalte zu machen.
Wie schaut das aus?
Das haben wir hier unser DataFrame,
wir wollen da jetzt eine neue Spalte hinzufügen,
dann können wir das einfach so machen,
dann haben wir hier eine neue Spalte mit dem Wert 1 drin stehen,
sagen wir mal, wir wollen hier was anderes haben, zum Beispiel,
Population, also ich kann zum Beispiel die Spalte kopieren einfach,
das geht auch,
jetzt habe ich hier einfach das gleiche drin stehen,
was ich hier drin stehen gehabt habe,
ich kann sagen, okay, ich will da das Ganze durch 1.000 machen,
dann schreibt es mir hier die Werte durch 1.000 rein,
also das ist jemals, wie ihr seht zum Beispiel 38 Millionen und hier steht dann 38.000 drin
und hier steht 26 Millionen drin und hier steht dann 26.000 drin,
ich kann aber hier dann auch wirklich zwei Spalten hernehmen,
und dann wird hier zum Beispiel Population durch Area dividiert für jede Spalte einzeln,
natürlich, wenn wir hier ein Missing Value haben,
dann kommt hier auch ein Missing Value raus,
oder wenn zum Beispiel der zweite, also hier Area Null ist,
wir können nicht durch Null dividieren, das heißt,
hier kommt auch ein Missing Value raus,
genau, und da kann man natürlich auch wieder hergehen und irgendwelche Beifunktionen verwenden,
zum Beispiel wollen wir die Population in Millionen hier runden,
dann können wir einfach Round und die gleiche Spalte nochmal reinhauen,
dann wird die eben gerundet,
hier zum Beispiel die zweite wird auf 2 Kommastellen gerundet,
und die erste wird auf keine Kommastelle gerundet,
dann kommen wir noch zum Plotting,
und Plotting ist auch richtig cool,
so haben wir hier zum Beispiel unser DataFrame,
dann können wir einfach sagen DataFrame.plot,
da gibt es natürlich verschiedene Plots,
also die kennt ihr wahrscheinlich eh alle,
da gibt es die Barplot, also die Säulendiagramme,
die Skatterplots und so weiter und so fort,
hier zum Beispiel machen wir ein Barplot,
also wir sagen unsere x-Axis ist der State,
unsere y-Axis ist die Population Density,
dann können wir da noch ein Titel definieren,
dann sagen wir okay, welche Art von Plot zu sein,
in diesem Fall soll es ein Barplot sein,
dann können wir auch die x-Achsen und die y-Achsen praktisch erlabeln,
und dann kriegen wir dann Plot raus,
und ihr kennt das wahrscheinlich eh von Excel,
da markiert man einfach die Spalten,
und sonst hat man einfügen neuer Plot,
ziemlich ähnlich hier nur, dass wir es praktisch
hier ganz schnell zum Beispiel die Art des Plots austauschen können,
oder die x- oder y-Achse austauschen können,
und man kann halt mit sehr sehr vielen Daten arbeiten,
obwohl das Plotding bei sehr sehr vielen Daten auch sehr langsam sein kann manchmal, leider.
Genau, am Anfang haben wir gehabt,
dass man aus CSV DataFrames erstellen kann,
man kann das Ganze natürlich umgekehrt auch machen,
man kann aus CSV DataFrames auch wieder CSV DataFrames machen,
man kann auch andere DataFrames rausmachen,
also man muss nicht nur CSV DataFrames machen,
man kann auch Excel DataFrames machen,
die sind ein bisschen anders,
aber ja im Großen und Ganzen schreibt man einfach df.2csv,
dann den Namen, den man haben möchte,
und hier zum Beispiel kann man dann angeben,
ob man den Index noch dazu haben will oder nicht,
also der Index, der wäre hier,
nicht 01234,
hier in diesem Fall haben wir gesagt,
nein wir wollen nicht,
wenn wir das hier vergessen,
dann haben wir hier automatisch 0123456 drin stehen.
Genau, und dann kriegen wir praktisch einfach,
also das schaut dann so aus,
wenn wir es mit Excel zum Beispiel aufmachen,
dann kriegen wir eben wieder das.
Genau, warte ich zeig das eventuell nochmal kurz.
Okay, zusammen wir wollen dieses DataFrame,
das wir jetzt haben, speichern,
dann können wir eben df.2csv,
und das sieht ja schon,
was alles möglich ist an DataEin,
also ich kann es zum Beispiel einfach ins Clipboard speichern,
das ist das Gleiche wie wenn ihr zum Beispiel kopieren,
also irgendwas Rechtsklick und Kopieren macht,
oder Steuerung C macht,
das wird dann praktisch einfach in der Ram gespeichert,
im Arbeitsspeicher,
ihr könnt zum Beispiel eben das Ganze in ein csv umwandeln,
ihr könnt aber auch einfach ein Beifendiktionell draus produzieren,
dann gibt es eben noch Excel und so weiter und so fort,
nehmen wir einfach mal csv her,
und wie ihr seht,
da gibt es Unmengen an Parametern,
die ihr da verwenden könnt.
Wir wollen jetzt mal zum ersten Mal den FileBuff haben,
ah, hier sieht man es besser,
also vielleicht kurz ein paar Parameter,
die ihr anwenden könnt,
also Puff oder Buff,
das ist praktisch dort der Filename,
wo ihr das csv speichern wollt,
haben zum Beispiel neues,
NewStates oder StatesProcess.csv,
dann könnt ihr den Separator auswählen,
der ist normalerweise einfach ein Komma,
aber wenn ihr sagt,
na, ich will alles Strichpunkt getrennt haben,
dann könnt ihr hier Separator Strichpunkt angeben,
oder Kanon kann man natürlich jeglichen String angeben,
den ihr haben wollt,
also das kann auch zum Beispiel Kanon Hallo sein,
und dann wird praktisch euer csv mit dem String Hallo getrennt,
das kann man auch kurz austesten.
Dann zum Beispiel,
wie MissingValues,
also fehlende Werte repräsentiert werden sollen,
die werden hier im nächsten Fall einfach in QuotationMarks gespeichert,
man kann natürlich auch auswählen,
welche Columns,
also wenn man zum Beispiel nicht alle Columns haben will,
kann man das auch auswählen,
ob man den Header speichern will,
also ob man zum Beispiel,
das ist unser Header hier,
also diese Fett markierten,
ob wir die auch speichern wollen oder nicht.
Den Index,
genau das haben wir erst schon gemacht,
ein Label für das Index,
den Mode zum Beispiel,
das ist eigentlich,
falls ihr erinnern könnt,
von den Files,
da kann man zum Beispiel,
also W ist für write,
also für schreiben,
aber man kann zum Beispiel auch A hernehmen,
zum Beispiel für appenden,
das heißt,
wenn das File schon existiert,
dann wird das nicht überschrieben,
sondern es wird einfach,
die neuen Daten einfach
ganz am Ende hinzugeflügt.
Die anderen sind jetzt nicht so wichtig,
aber ja,
die könnt ihr ja alle durchlesen.
Jetzt machen wir da einfach states new,
also was,
wenn ich da jetzt das Punkt CSV nicht mache,
dann macht es mir hier ein File,
das keine Endung hat.
Also die Werte drinnen
sind natürlich immer noch
gleich wie bei einem CSV-File,
aber euer Betriebssystem weiß nicht,
dass es ein CSV-File ist,
das heißt, ich muss hier Punkt CSV schreiben,
dann weiß das Betrieb ist dem AOK,
du meinst, ein Komma separiert das,
der Wellenformat.
Genau,
hier irgendwas gedrückt.
Die Lecture ist weg.
Dann kann man kurz zum separator vielleicht,
also wie gesagt,
der ist normalerweise Komma,
also wenn ihr den separator nicht angeht,
dann wird der Automatisch auf Komma gesetzt,
aber ihr könnt da eben Strichpunkt verwenden,
ihr könnt da eine Oderzei verwenden,
ihr könnt da,
keine Ahnung,
separator schreiben,
wenn ihr unbedingt haben wollt,
so was passiert da,
habe ich was vergessen.
Okay, geht tatsächlich nicht,
also der separator muss anscheinend
ein Zeichen lang sein,
dann habe ich ja Bullshit erzählt.
Okay, aber das geht.
Wie ihr seht,
haben wir dann eben hier
eine Oderzei hindern stehen.
Genau,
wenn ich da jetzt noch Heter dazu mache,
oh,
ist das hier Automatisch,
was kann ich nicht,
ob das,
okay ich glaube,
Heter ist automatisch auf True,
maybe.
Ja,
sagen wir mal,
ihr wollt die Heter nicht haben,
da sind die jetzt da oben weg,
also da fehlt jetzt die erste Zeile,
gibt es da zu fragen.
Okay,
schau, ob ich da noch irgendwo
das Apfel blotten.
Ja, genau,
also da gibt es alles Mögliche,
in diesem Fall zum Beispiel
verwenden wir einen By-Chart,
hier einen By-Chart,
ich werde euch dann noch dieses Notebook
hochladen ins Citycenter,
dann könnt ihr da eventuell
auch nochmal nachschauen.
Genau,
ja das glaube ich,
war es dann eh schon von der Banders.
Vorlesung,
gibt es dazu noch Fragen?
Okay,
dann vielleicht dann kurz
was Organisatorisches,
was jetzt noch auf euch zukommt.
Wir sind,
das heißt,
sollte eigentlich Assignment 2 sein,
also die Ausgabe wird jetzt
in den nächsten paar Tagen kommen,
es hat sich bis sich verzögert,
weil wir jetzt eben mal
kurze SimPy-Aufgabe einbauen werden,
aber ihr bekommt dann eine E-Mail.
Nächste Woche machten der Helmut noch
über SimPy einen Crash Course,
dann am 4. Feb,
praktisch ist keine Vorlesung,
und dann am 11.
haben wir dann die Classeur-Vorbereitung,
da wiederholen wir noch mal alles,
was ihr für die Classeur braucht.
Am 4. Feb ist dann eh schon,
dass die Deadline für Assignment 2,
ist seit eh schon alle in Gruppen
angemeldet,
nämlich an im Dietz-Center,
und dann,
ja, falls die Classeur
im Nicht-Hin-Haus holt,
dann gibt es eben noch eine Nachclasseur.
Zu den Tutorien habe ich da auch noch,
da wird dann nächste Woche
noch mal das Ganze durchgemacht,
was wir jetzt in den letzten
zwei Crash Crosses durchgemacht haben,
dann am 3.
wahrscheinlich haben wir SimPy-Tutorium,
und am 10. Dezember gibt es
noch mal eine Fragestunde zu Assignment 2,
falls es noch Unklarheiten gibt, ja.
Man muss sich für die Classeur
nicht anwenden, nein.
Die ist dann ein,
eigentlich ein Dietz-Center-Quiz,
das könnt ihr dann
zu Hause online machen.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
braucht ihr dafür
für die Classeur auch noch mal
50 Prozent der Punkte.
Genau, ja,
da haben wir jetzt alles durchgemacht,
hoffentlich.
Dann gehe ich kurz
zu Assignment 2 über
und erkläre kurz
was wir
Assignment 2 ablaufen wird.
Es hat sich eigentlich
seit letzten Jahren nicht viel geändert.
Es ist immer noch Data Science
für Civil Engineers.
Was heißt das?
Ja, ihr müsst damit banden,
bis ihr was arbeitet,
und das soll so ein bisschen simulieren,
wie das wirklich in der Realität
vielleicht auch aussehen könnte.
Das heißt,
ihr betreibt da Data Science
in eurem Anwendungsfeld,
und wir haben da Daten
von Vorarlberger Ski-Liften
und Seilbahnen,
mit denen ihr dann arbeiten könnt.
Und Ziel ist es da
praktisch, bis die Bahnen das
können zu lernen
und damit was zu programmieren.
Und dieses Assignment
ist im Jahr in Teilen aufgedeilt.
Ein Punkt bekommt ihr schon
allein aus Daten laden.
Das sollte jetzt kein Problem sein
mit ReadCSV.
Dann nochmal Pre-Processing.
Pre-Processing, was heißt das?
Ja, bevor wir mit den Daten
überhaupt was anfangen wollen,
müssen wir überhaupt schauen,
dass die Daten gut aussehen.
Das heißt, ob wir müssen
die missing values zum Beispiel entfernen
oder falls irgendwelche values
nicht stimmen sollen,
zum Beispiel wenn ein 0 drin steht,
dann müssen wir das nachschauen
und eventuell ausbessern.
Und das machen wir dann alles mit Code.
Und dann eigentlich
gibt es noch die Exploration und Visualisierung.
Das heißt praktisch,
ich schaute euch die Daten an
und plaudert es dann mal
auf bestimmte Spalten oder so
und seht es okay.
Keine Ahnung, es gibt 20 Ski-Lifte
oder die insgesamt,
die gesamte Länge aller Ski-Lifte
ist 50 Kilometer oder so.
Also da kann man wie sie schauen,
wie schauen die Daten überhaupt aus,
statt dass man immer nur ne Tabelle hat.
Und dann das ganze Schluss.
Also das ist praktisch der erste Teil
und dann gibt es den zweiten Teil,
das ist praktisch eine Analyse
und Berechnung,
wo ihr noch mal 12,5 Punkte bekommt
und da werden wir dieses Mal
noch ein bisschen SimPy inkludieren.
Und ja, das ist dann auch einfach
noch mal,
da gibt man dann noch mal tiefer rein,
sucht sich bald durch einen bestimmten Punkt aus,
wo man sagt okay,
das möchte ich mir genauer anschauen,
also möchte ich mir genauer analysieren,
zum Beispiel,
das Beispiel selber nicht ganz genau.
Aber hier nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal
ein grobes Beispiel her und sag,
ich nehme jetzt die Länge
aller Ski-Liftes 50 Kilometer
und ich nehme jetzt die Länge,
was kann ich mit dem anfangen.
Das Beispiel,
wie hoch ist zum Beispiel der Preis
pro Kilometer,
den ich dafür gezahlt habe
oder wie viel Gewinn kann ich
pro Kilometer Ski-Lift einnehmen.
Das ist nur ein Beispiel,
ich glaube,
das ist dann ein bisschen anders,
immer sei man zwei, aber
aber ja, so was könnte ich darunter vorstellen.
Für die Abgabe,
also die Abgabe ist dann einfach
das ist die Beschreibung,
die ihr dann bekommen werdet,
das ist dann eigentlich so ziemlich
gleich wie Simon 1.
Die Deadline ist dann Mitternacht am 14.
Und da gibt ihr dann einfach
dieses Simon 2 Punkt Notebook ab,
also dieses IPNB.
Ja, die Anforderungen und Output
sind da exakt wiederzugeben,
warum?
Ja, weil wir da wieder
das Testsystem verwenden.
Also wir werden da auch wieder
beim Testsystem,
also dieses Testsystem
mehrmals durchlaufen lassen,
also jeweils Dienstag und Freitag.
Ich rate euch da wirklich sehr,
das auszunutzen,
weil ihr da auch wirklich
blöde Fehler draufkommt,
könnt ihr die vielleicht durch Punkte abziehen.
Ja, dieses Mal muss der Kommentarheader,
ah, wo sind da beide Dateien?
Also einfach in allen Dateien,
die ihr dann abgeben solltet,
sollte dieser Kommentarheader ausgefüllt werden.
Und Codingstander soll auch wieder eingehalten werden.
Ja, genau, zum Automatisieren Test nehmen,
VIPAS 1 mit 1.
Also wenn ihr alle Tests erfolgreich bestanden habt,
muss das nicht heißen,
dass ihr alle Punkte bekommt,
weil wir natürlich auch noch
im Hintergrund Tests haben,
also am Ende mit anderen Werten,
die wir nochmal austesten werden.
Deshalb seid gefasst,
dass ihr da wirklich alle Kleinigkeiten durchgedacht habt
und dann sollte es eigentlich
hier trotzdem kein Problem sein.
Genau, Testruns, Dienstags und Freitags,
wir werden dann wieder einfach die Abgaben
ab 18 Uhr downloaden und testen
und dann bekommt ihr wieder per Mail
praktisch ein Feedback.
Und falls ihr wirklich da Fragen habt
zum Testreport,
dann kommt ihr eben ins Tutorium
oder schreibt es einfach in die Center,
sagt okay, ich habe diesen Fehler bekommen
im Feedback Report.
Ich verstehe nicht,
könnt ihr bitte uns da weiterhelfen.
Und da werden wir versuchen,
das so schnell wie möglich zu beantworten.
Ja, das ist es eigentlich eh schon
von diesem Crash Course.
Gibt es sonst noch Fragen?
Sonst würde ich mich bedanken.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Da doch hier steht,
im beiden Dateien,
ja also ich denke schon,
dass ihr praktisch da zusammen
in einer Datei arbeiten könnt.
Also ihr könnt es,
ich will jetzt nichts Blödes sagen,
weil ich das selber jetzt nicht weiß,
aber ich kann mir halt gut vorstellen,
dass ihr wahrscheinlich
einfach entweder zu zweit euch zusammensetzt
und das Gemeinsam programmiert
und dann einfach
für jeweils pro Person
das gleiche File auf Teach Center hochlett.
Da bekommt ihr jetzt kein Plagiat.
Ich meine, das macht ihr zusammen.
Das ist ja eigentlich die...
Ihr sollt natürlich das nicht
mit zwei verschiedenen Gruppen machen,
aber ja, es ist einfach so,
also es ist eine Gruppenarbeit.
Das heißt, ihr könnt das ruhig zu zweit
gemeinsam auf einem Computer machen.
Wenn ihr das nicht möglich ist,
dann könnt ihr das auch über Karnung,
Discord machen oder Karnung.
Also das ist alles möglich.
Okay, was?
Falls ihr sonst keine Fragen gibt,
dann vielen Dank.
Dann lasse ich euch...